so he's written I think five or six
best-selling business books non-fiction
business books air business life hack
type books and if he was going to do
just another one of those it would have
been like okay cool like you know just
going back to the you know what butter
is your brand right that's that makes
sense but instead he's like I'm gonna
build like a world like Game of Thrones
and he's like I'm gonna build a whole
thing right like this like it's an
entire fantasy world
all the characters are roosters okay
there's eight houses they compete in the
great games and they do this like you
know then you know there's a war and
there's different classes and there's
all the all the things like if you
create like a sort of a giant fantasy
like you know Tolkien or or George R
Martin style thing and
along with it there's like basically an
nft which you can buy that basically is
not like is is literally just like
you're buying a piece of art and you're
buying a ticket into the entertainment
of like watching him build this world
[Music]
what's up in this episode we're talking
about hanging out with Tim Ferriss a guy
that we've looked up to for a long time
and some of the insights that he he
shared with us we talked about uh
meeting a real estate billionaire and
his model how he built from scratch in
seven years to about a billion dollars
in real estate assets we talked about
the opportunity to build SAS tools for
only fans yeah you're going to want to
hear that and then last but not least
Sam's got a uh a friend who's created
his own I don't know religion sort of
like the Amish people who love money
kinda it is almost like Amish people who
love money I'm going to this thing I'm
going to give a big update on it next
week but in this episode when we start
off I'll tell you a little bit about it
I think you're gonna dig it but yes
that's the episode listen up all right
we live can I tell you about an
interesting call ahead with uh with your
old pal Tim Ferriss I'm so eager to hear
this I only asked you a few questions
because I was waiting to hear about this
so I interviewed Tim Ferriss because
he's got like a new nft project that
came out today or it's coming out today
and um
yeah called punch right so I was
like okay
what's that about and
um I was like yo you should come on the
milk Road and like tell your story and
um blah blah blah and I've met Tim
Ferriss one time in my life you've met
him a lot more than that I think because
he was an investor in the hustle and was
kind of like it lived around the same
area as you or whatever but I've met him
one time and I guess I'll just I want to
tell you three things one
it's pretty interesting to meet people
who you've
really gotten to know through their
content uh what was it the the only fans
girl who came on here called it the
parasocial relationship where it's like
I feel like I know a lot about you and
to you I'm a complete stranger but you
know I I feel like we're close friends
because I know so much about you and you
don't even know who the hell I am that's
how I feel with Tim Ferriss that's how
people feel with you and I I bet yeah it
happens with with you and I um and you
know I was like well and it's just like
a weird dynamic it's not weird it's not
like bad or good it's like a strange
Dynamic it's a natural thing that
happens with content like this so I read
the four hour work week when I was in
college and I got yo before covid-19
there was the four hour fever and the
four hour fever was what happened to you
right when you read that book for the
next four hours you question every part
of your life and you start fever
dreaming about quitting everything you
know hiring a VA to do your job going
and living in Argentina and you know
like basically creating some online
passive income business is going to give
you 7K a month because that's your
freedom number and so like and I know
this because everybody I gave the book
to I'm like look you might want to clear
the schedule because you're going to
have the four hour fever as soon as
you're done with this uh like just don't
make plans because whatever they are
they're gonna get busted by this and
sure enough that's exactly what happened
so for our work week was one of those
books that I found to be really really
life-changing uh informative
life-changing especially at the time
that I read it I was 20 21 years old
trying to figure out what I wanted to do
with my life and um it was a new it was
somebody saying you know here's how I
live and it was totally different than
anybody else okay so that's how I knew
him
um you knew him in a different way can
you describe how you knew them and then
I went to tell you some of the takeaways
I had from this interview so I initially
met him when I was I was coming home at
six a.m from the hospital after I got a
kidney stone my wife was driving me and
I was sitting in the passenger seat and
I was super messed up on morphine and
all types of drugs and I pull up to my
house and I go Sarah
what the hell is Tim Ferriss doing in
front of our house and uh I see him I go
Tim
what's up bro what are you doing here
and uh he's like oh I looked on the
pocket it's like oh sick hey you got any
uh cures for kidney stones and I just
sounded like a total and then
two days later I see him again I go Tim
what's going on man I just want to
apologize I I was come from the hospital
I was all hopped up in drugs but I'm a
huge fan that's cool that you're you're
you live around here and then through
that we just started walking our dogs
like in the park every once in a while
together and I would just see him in the
park then a few weeks later I get an
email from Tim saying hey I want to
learn about emailing I like the hustle
teach me about it can you go out you can
when you meet me at this restaurant in
my neighborhood I go and meet him at
that restaurant he goes oh what the hell
you're the dog guy I go what's up man he
goes why don't you so I basically he
cold emailed me and I never told him who
I was and it was a total coincidence and
and that's how I got to know him so
I want to say two things one
I'm gonna tell people My Philosophy
about meeting people that you kind of
you know admire or you think highly of
in some way
and the main trick that I have is I
admire parts of people not the whole
totally and this is a key key thing that
I think a lot of people get wrong they
look at it as a binary yes or no thing
oh this person do you love them or do
you do you hate them right are they the
best are they the worst right are they
are they your hero are they not your
hero and I never think like that because
when you meet people you see this like
full 360 picture of them and you're like
oh like no for example I'm at Tim
Ferriss and who's actually quite quiet
in person the first time he's super
quiet and uh he's a little bit
introverted or shy and um and then when
he did say things I was like uh oh wow
that's like a little bit of the Tim
Ferriss that I you know I've heard or
followed coming out
but also I was like you know even though
I love 10 things about this guy there's
a couple things about him that I
wouldn't want to emulate right there's
six things I'd want to copy let's say
about the way that Tim Ferriss lives his
life but
I was like oh you know something that's
really important to me is like let's say
kids are having a family and I don't
know if it's important to him or not I
don't know him that well but he doesn't
have that so I don't wanna I don't want
to be him right I don't want to be whole
but there's parts of him that I think
are awesome that I would love to steal
from my game and I think about this with
everybody I imagine you like standing
over him and he's just sitting down in
your Pokemon with a stick and you're
like come on tell me life hacks like
come on what you did with your kidney
stone things like you ever seen you have
one of these on your feet what do you do
yeah
maybe you should ask a doctor
and so
same thing with Tony Robbins I love Tony
Robbins
but do I love the whole Tony Robbins no
I love parts of Tony Robbins and some
people are like dude what about that
thing he did or that thing he said oh my
God I don't I mean I don't know about
that and if he did those that that would
be bad but I love his public speaking I
think he's amazing at that and that's
what I try to steal from right or I love
his mindset around XYZ and that's what
I've adopted from and that's been really
helpful and this other stuff that's
either not applicable or not admirable
no it's fine I just don't take that
right I'm just walking through the
farmer's market picking up little bits
and pieces of people and being like Oh
you know like Conor McGregor now is like
basically looks like he's like a roid
head you know like Coke I don't know
he's got allegations of sexual assault
and he's just coked out or who knows
this guy's nuts but like Conor McGregor
from the years 2015 to 2018 yeah you
know what they call the young hungry
Connor that's the counter I liked that
was the things I drew a lot from and I
don't let the other stuff really tarnish
that because I'm just only looking for
the good and the bad I just say oh
somebody else can pick that that bad
apple up I'm not taking that out all
right so what about that so that's just
my general philosophy okay so let me
tell you some of the Nuggets that I took
away from this interview because it was
supposed to be I mean Frankly Speaking
it was supposed to be like
to first comes on the milk Road that's
cool that's sort of like a bucket list
item thing for me but
you know for him obviously it was a good
way to get the word out about his nft
project so I thought I went in with like
you know pretty low expectations
generally when somebody goes on to like
announce the launch of something they're
kind of just chilling that thing he
didn't do that so that was kind of cool
and he said a bunch of things that were
I would I would say life advice or money
advice that I thought were interesting
do you want the money or the life one
first money
all right money one so I was like what
Tim what are you doing now crypto prices
are crashing what are you doing
um are you making any adjustments do you
look at the prices he's a crypto guy by
the way
yeah he said he bought crypto Bill
bought Bitcoin for the first time but
like late 2012 and been accumulating
kind of since he's like it's a you know
significant thing for me not like you
know not everything but it's significant
they said last year Q3 2021 he sold
enough to cover like feel like he kind
of covered his cost basis and banked a
little bit of a win and then the rest
he's just like you know holding to to
see how it all plays out and he was like
he said a couple interesting things he
goes
I've made most of my money mistakes
selling early selling too early and he
gave a bunch of examples he goes you
know I owned I was the first advisor in
Shopify super early on and I owned
pre-ipo shares of Twitter and Facebook
and as soon as they went public uh you
know uh you know yeah so they grow they
go public and you know in that first
year they all hit like turbulent times
and they you know stock went way down
he's like I just as soon as a lockup was
over I just sold because Stock's going
down I was kind of a novice in public
markets frankly still a bit of a novice
in public markets I didn't know what to
do so I just sold all of it it's like
yeah all of it I think he didn't specify
that but he made it sound like all of it
wow and he's like those are massive
Financial mistakes you know like selling
Facebook Shopify and Twitter like right
when they went public
um you know six months after is when the
lockup ends is you know he's like these
are you know hideous Financial mistakes
that I made he's like and it wasn't
because
I he's like there's he's like he's like
so I learned what when do you sell so he
goes I now go into any position I only
buy if I know what conditions I would
sell under he's like so most people have
no exit plan they don't know when they
would sell how long they plan to hold or
what would cause them to sell he's like
I now have a plan when I go in I know
what would trigger me to sell so if I'm
going to deviate from that plan I better
have a really strong reason because the
second thing is I don't sell now because
you know the price went down I sell if
something I believe before I now have
new information that tells me that's not
true anymore or I'm surprised about he's
like so for crypto for example he's like
I haven't sold but I haven't sold that
because I'm like
you know more confident than ever he was
frankly I just haven't done the homework
to go figure out where any of my initial
assumptions wrong I haven't done that
homework yet and he's like that's what
I'll do I'll go talk to my smart friends
the ones who help me get into this and
I'll say you know
is there anything that you used to
believe that you no longer believe about
crypto or anything that any red flags
that have come up for you that didn't go
in line with your initial hypotheses I
want to hear those before I make a
decision on what I want to do I thought
that was extremely reasonable and I
thought that the the sort of selling
early uh mistake is something that you
know I I've shared on the Pod too that
you know like I sold Tesla early when
there was like you know I basically lost
5 million I lost out on five million
dollars had I held
um but I you know there was a bunch of
bad news and I didn't know what to do
and so then I just sold right and by the
way for the Shopify example it looks
like six months after it was around two
dollars and fifty cents a share at its
peak at its peak Peak it was a hundred
and fifty dollars so that's something
like you know a million dollars of
shares that he had which he definitely
could have had would have been like 50
million dollars uh which is like very
substantial
and so he was pointing out you know my
mistakes in investing haven't been
buying the wrong thing the biggest
mistakes have been selling the right
thing too early and you know that I
think that might be you know he's like
you know I don't know if this applies to
everybody's like for me that has been
you know some of my largest kind of uh
missteps
um okay so then the second thing he was
talking about uh this project that he's
doing this nft project and I was like so
this is kind of crazy I don't know if
you know what do you know what he's
doing I know that he's always been
interested in non-fiction writing or
sorry fiction writing like he's always
wanted to write like stories and for
some reason he hasn't until now right
and I think this is like his first
fictional story or book or series of
podcasts and it comes with an nft right
yeah exactly so he's written I think
five or six best-selling business books
non-fiction business books and business
life hack type books and if he was going
to do just another one of those it would
have been like okay cool like you know
going back to the you know what butter
is your bread right that's that makes
sense but instead he's like I'm gonna
build like a world like Game of Thrones
and he's like I'm gonna build a whole
thing or like this like it's an entire
fantasy world
all the characters are roosters okay
there's eight houses they compete in the
great games and they do this like you
know then you know there's a war and
there's different classes and there's
all the all the things like if you
create like a sort of a giant fantasy
like you know Tolkien or or George R
Martin style thing and
along with it there's like basically an
nft which you can buy that basically is
not like is is literally just like
you're buying a piece of art and you're
buying a ticket into the entertainment
of like watching him build this world
out it's a book like one book
it it's not a book it's like I think
it's just like long he's like I've
written 10 000 words but uh I don't
think he's gonna release it like a book
I think he's gonna release it in some
other way like essays or chapters or
podcasts and like other okay he's
playing with different formats I don't
think he knows exactly how he wants it
to come out yet so anyways pretty
interesting I was like dude so why are
you doing this he's like well he said a
couple nuggets he goes
you know I'm having the most fun when
I'm creating something and that's what
gets me into Flow State and so he's like
so I knew I wanted to create something
and I wanted to
if I just did another nonfiction book I
don't feel like I would have that
magical feeling of being challenged and
satisfied at the same time yeah
um and so he goes he goes I talked to
the guy from who did Stephen pressfield
who I think wrote uh the war of art yeah
um
and he goes he goes you know
um he has this concept of a muse which
is like the project you're working on or
like you know the thing that you're
you're playing with and he goes you're
doing your Muse a disservice if you
don't go big
and uh he goes so I decided like if I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna go big and he
goes like big is not
um I have to write like an 8 000 word
book or whatever like it doesn't page
book like that's big doesn't mean like
literal volume big means I have to go to
a point where I'm uncomfortable with
this and my friends are calling me and
they're saying Tim are you okay sure
this is what you want to do and he's
like that's how I know that I've like
pushed it into a realm that's like
something interesting is gonna happen
and that's how I feel with this
yeah what's up with this podcast what do
you mean no with him coming up with a
non-fiction thing called or a fiction
thing yeah you want to call him and be
like I'm like yeah I'm like you know you
have nothing to lose here because like
you know you're set you're fine and if
this is creative that's cool but like
it's kind of weird what do you what what
are you doing man like are you okay
yeah exactly and he goes That's when I'm
gonna basically do the things that are
off the beaten path something that I
haven't done before something that is
new and interesting and novel and so
that's how he was talking about this
thing I was like okay I love that advice
um the second thing he said it was along
those lines he goes
um he goes I go so I go what if we're
just sitting here like you know a year
from now she's got a beer we're like
dude what happened with punch man
that story was that was going to be that
project was crazy like where did it all
go wrong like if it all goes wrong what
do you think your answer will be if
we're we're looking back at it a year
from now and it's just like the yeah
that went that went totally wrong what
is the core risk it goes
I've thought about this a lot it's a
good question he goes
if I end up managing the project instead
of creating it I think it will have all
gone wrong he goes because a he goes
he goes anything great comes from you
know staying at it he goes so I have to
do the things that give me energy
because without the energy there is no
endurance
and that like really resonated with me
he was like you know with no energy
there is no endurance he goes so I gotta
spend my time on the things that give me
energy for me that's drawing and that's
creative writing so I have to do those
parts that's also the parts that those
are my superpowers that's what I'm good
at and I'm doing better like like you
did in the background was like
illustrations and Comics like that's how
hey really stuff like that yeah he's
like a sketch artist and I think that's
what he originally wanted to do was be a
cartoonist in some way
and so he was like you know those are my
superpowers I gotta spend the time on
that if I just end up spending time
managing this thing and it feels like a
lot of administrative work I know that
for me that gives me no energy therefore
no endurance therefore I won't stay stay
with it therefore the great things won't
happen I thought the self-awareness was
really key and this is something that I
know as I think about my next projects
these are the types of like
you need to have like these strong ass
pillars or tenets of like this is what
it this is what I am doing this is what
I'm not doing and if I do this I think
it'll work and if I don't do this I know
that I will have trouble and I think
that self-awareness is pretty baller
dude that's awesome he's he's always
been a pretty wise person even like you
know I think he wrote four-hour work
week when he was maybe a little bit
younger than you and I like at he might
have been only 30 when he wrote it and
he always was pretty wise man he's he's
always had like interesting insight and
that's a really good insight about the
energy and the endurance thing he had
another one that goes he goes I go so
um I was on the topic of failure he goes
he goes I should first say that I kind
of rigged the deck in my favor and I was
like what do you mean and he goes you
know I um I go into a project thinking
how do I win even if this fails how do I
succeed even at the sales and so he goes
I think about it in terms of sure
there's the like you know um do a lot of
people read this thing and you know does
this become popular or does it become
financially successful sure those are
things but like he's like I want to win
even if those hard things don't happen
so he goes I will only pick projects if
I know that the act of doing it the
creative process of doing it is going to
be awesome if the people I'm gonna meet
along the way doing this are going to be
awesome and if the skills that I'm going
to develop doing this are going to make
me more awesome and so he goes if I do
those three things if I know that the
skills the knowledge and the network
that I acquire along the way is gonna
make it worth it for me then I don't
have to stress about the the popularity
of the financial income because I'm
going to win in either case I'm going to
win if just those things happen or I'm
gonna win even bigger if the other
happens so he goes I pick projects where
I can stack the deck in my favor and
that's what I've done here and is this
still the life it or the money advice or
the life one
now we're in the Life advice yeah dude
he's good man he's a really interesting
guy I uh what's he doing now so he just
like is he is he treating that as like
that's been his like 40 Hour Work Week
like that's been his job job uh yeah
he's been he's just going ham on this
for like you know close to a year now
and he's like dude I've just put so many
so many hours into this he's like you
know which is funny because people are
criticizing like oh dude you're doing an
nft or just like another celebrity doing
an nft it's just a cash grab and I like
I told him this on the call I was like
dude that's crazy to me first of all
he's donating 100 of the proceeds to
like his charity that does like the
research on like psychedelics and stuff
like that to treat PTSD so so all the
primary sales are going there right uh
so that's like you know most you know
that's a huge chunk of the financial
reason you would do it uh the second
thing is
um if you just count like the number of
hours it takes to do this world building
type of thing like he's got to be
working for minimum wage basically just
in terms of the number of hours it takes
to create something like this and third
if he was going to do a cash grab nft he
would have done it last last year he
wouldn't be launching it now and he
wouldn't be giving away the money to
charity and he would be like doing it in
a way that's like not doesn't require
him to like build out this whole
fictional world like he would just be
like hey here's a picture or hey meet
this you know this gives you five
minutes to talk to Tim Ferriss right
that's what he would do is just like a
cash grab if he wanted to do it and so I
thought that was like you know dude
funny criticism Tim has like a really
interesting celebrity Ryan holiday has
this too and I know I've known a few
guys that have had this where there's
people I look up to and then there's
people
who the people I look up to look up to
so like Ryan and Tim they both get like
all these football coaches all these
like politicians these rich billionaire
types all these interesting like
powerful traditionally powerful people
will reach out to them and like hey
Sensei show me the way what can I do
about this what should I do next and
I've always found that type of celebrity
to be incredibly fascinating and so like
I mean he'll Tim will like not in a bad
way but he'll like name drop all these
stories like on the pot I'll be like
yeah you know I was with Ed Norton
recently and he was telling me like this
this and this and I was trying to help
him like figure out what to do you know
like he like tells these stories or like
when I was with Jamie Foxx he was asking
me about this and uh I've always found
that celebrity be so fascinating I've
always wondered what his life is like
I also I asked him another question I go
you know you're one of the most like
prolific interviewers you've done I
don't know 600 episodes of of interviews
on your podcast it's one of the top I
don't know five or ten podcasts in the
world and
um as I go you know if you had a chance
to sit down with Sam bankman freed uh
and interview him you got a couple hours
with them how would you approach it and
I thought his answer was pretty
interesting so he goes
he goes it's a tricky one because I
don't know going in how much of what
he's gonna tell me is the truth or a lie
and so he goes but I'll tell you how I
would approach it given that that's the
problem he goes first I would
my goal initially is just to get him off
of his party lines get him off of his PR
script and so he's like I would go and I
would try to talk to as many of his old
friends and co-workers as I can and ask
them yo if I if you you know you must be
surprised at what's happened here if you
could ask Sam one question just
genuinely Heart to Heart what would you
want to know the answer to that I can
maybe ask on your behalf and then he's
like I get those he's like then in the
interview I would use their name to kind
of soften soften them up a little bit so
I talked to James who you know should
call Drew mate and knew you before any
of this stuff right when you were just a
guy blah blah uh you know he said he
would want to know this like what would
you say to James because it's like
saying to James versus sanctity I think
it's like interesting so I thought that
was an interesting tactic he goes that
gives me good research but also maybe
can get him to just like deviate from
the same repetitive Loop of answers he's
going to give to everybody else he knows
the second thing he goes I'd be pretty
direct I go what percent of what you say
to you know before we do this what
percent should I assume is true of the
things that you're going to tell me is
it a hundred or is it less than a
hundred and like you know if it's less
than 100 I understand that but why
anyways another version of that would be
you're doing a lot of media
um
what do you what do your lawyers think
of what you're doing he's like because
it might make him laugh and get him to
kind of talk about his motivations for
why he's even doing an interview like
this because it seems kind of
counterintuitive to be doing all the
stuff no lawyer would tell you to go go
on
do this stuff he goes the last thing he
goes he goes you know I would um
it goes I would he goes I just want to
know the guy's fundamental beliefs
because it seems like he's not stupid
he's got good Hardware upstairs and
that's why I want to know what his
beliefs are uh you know am I just
supposed to assume that he's just a bad
person he was a criminally minded person
and for a long time he planned to do
this criminal Behavior or was he did he
have the right intentions and then
somewhere along the way made a bad
ethical decision under some stress or
pressure and that led him down a path of
making the wrong decisions you know like
and he's like that's what I'd be trying
to figure out and you know I would try
to
um
to understand you know his uh you know
his thinking around that and tell him
that's what I want to know I want to
understand that I thought that was
pretty cool so I'll I'll wrap up with
one last story about Tim so and this
what you're saying kind of like he'll
he'll say these things sometimes in
interviews as if he's coming off the
cuff or that he's like just thinking out
loud
I have never met someone like him who
prepares for everything he prepares for
every single thing
and this is quite different than you and
I you and I are totally cool improvising
and you would think someone like him
who's interviewed all these people or
has talked publicly for so many hours
that they can improvise maybe he can but
from my experience he is not someone who
improvises and he everything he says the
words are chosen very very specifically
and so you like he'll say this line like
oh I don't play a doctor on TV and I
don't pretend to do that like he'll say
that line and like that's just like he
must have heard that somewhere he's like
okay that's actually a good line to get
that's a good brand message disarm yeah
I'm gonna keep saying that and so
another thing that he'll do is like
one time I interviewed him for the
hustle
and I interviewed him on the phone and
then I transcribed it and there was a
couple instances where I made an heir so
he was right to yell at me and he didn't
yell at me but he was just like no this
is that's not what I said and we're
talking about like I I would write the
word hadn't instead of had not he said
had not and I wrote hadn't so I was in
fact wrong and he like very specifically
called that out and he did that so or
he's like no there shouldn't be a comma
here there should be a period and then a
new sentence or like these like
incredibly incredibly if he did that
then he's gonna be pretty pissed at this
interview because I definitely dude you
know move stuff around to help him no he
does not like that and I don't blame him
he's so specific about his brand and in
fact if you go and see the like for
example there's this conference called
212 that I went to and Tim went and he
gave a testimonial for it and if you
read the testimonial it's very specific
where in his head he's like why I can't
endorse anything like but like what I
can't say is you know Adam hosted a
great conference they're wonderful he's
he's a wonderful person or like like you
know like some people will ask us you
and I like I've asked you to do a
testimonial for something and you're
like just write whatever uh no not him
everything about his brand like what you
see out in public and what he writes he
is very specific and it's all incredibly
well thought out so like we almost had
him speak at a conference or something
like that and we just like went through
we just started chatting about it and he
was like wanting to know exactly who all
was there and I'm like what do you mean
dude why does it matter to you just like
wing it just talk and like
that's not his style at all like it it
was all incredibly precise well thought
out it's all and everything had a
purpose and I've I've always found that
to be very admirable about him because I
remember being pissed off when he he
didn't yell at me but like he kind of
like had a tone where he's like no
that's not what I said this is what I
said I remember being upset about that
and then I was like nah man he's right
he's he he's has a brain and he's
sticking to it and I always thought that
was really interesting
yeah well all right Tim I'm sorry I did
uh definitely chop and chop up for the
interview to to try to make it shorter
and better when to go live went to go
live it's already live too late tell me
if he replies to you that's gonna be the
follow-up I bet you he will he he
honestly he's very specific about it and
I appreciate that you're right I had
told him I was like um he's like he's
like yeah I'll do it uh you know just
send me the questions in advance so I
want to make sure I can prepare and to
do the best job I can and I was like
well I don't know the questions I'm
gonna ask you so uh okay I guess I'll do
the work now and so I did it and then
he's like okay cool uh for this question
I think we should do this and this and
this and I was like wow this is like way
more in depth than anybody and then even
during the thing he's like
he's like I did an audio video test
earlier blah blah blah it should be good
because he's like you know whatever in
some foreign country right now and he's
like you know I am
um and then on some of the answers she's
like okay stop can we um can I redo that
I think I was just not being clear there
and then he would like do it again and I
was like wow we're so different but I
get why being the way that you are leads
you to have the type of brand and and
success that you have
um I am so different than that I am like
you know
complete I'm basically like the
equivalent of a food fight and he's like
a Michelin star restaurant exactly
you're like so fascinating throwing
mashed potatoes around and getting it
everywhere and he's like you know got
that perfect place dude I remember we
were with our dogs like walking and I go
oh that's a cool dog leash and like or
like cool dog collar or something and he
and I was expecting him to be like oh
yeah I got an Amazon's pretty great he
was like oh this thing you see this
comes from like this rare like African
horse hair and like he had like some
in-depth story about it and that was my
friend and then I noticed every time
something like we had these
conversations everything about his life
it felt very purposeful High intense
intentional yeah I thought that was
fascinating
yeah that's cool uh it really highlights
like it's like you see a 12 out of 10 at
being very intentional and then you're
like oh wow I thought I might have been
an eight or a nine actually I'm a four
totally he's very specific
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better all right
you want to do another one of yours yeah
let's do some other topics Okay so
uh where do you want to shift to maybe
some ideas uh what's the is Spotify
interesting or real estate insights
that's I'm interested in that you said
maybe but all right let me give you the
real estate thing real quick so I talked
to somebody I can't say their name
but uh who
has had who's built I would say in the
last seven years I think it is yes seven
years
they've built a real estate portfolio
owning about a billion dollars of real
estate assets
where with 40 debt
um so 60 is equities about 600 million
of equity in these properties
and do I know this started seven years
ago
um
from zero and has zero ability to like
zero networks your ability to borrow
only like skills they knew they thought
they knew what they were doing and they
were able to build this up okay so I was
talking to him and I was like
I was like you'd and he does retail in a
specific he does retail real estate so
basically uh or I guess in their world
they would call it commercial real
estate but what I mean is like retail
stores so he'll buy a shopping center
and the shopping center will have a
um you know a Hobby Lobby and
um you know a Starbucks and whatever and
there's like you know six spots and
he'll basically own that Center and then
he'll he'll get at least he'll buy it
he'll build on it he'll lease it up and
then he'll either hold it or sell it
after that
and
he's basically compounded his money I
think about I was doing the calculations
afterwards
um he's compounded his money about 60 a
year
um for like you know seven years or
something like that even maybe even a
little bit more
um and so I think 60 was the minimum
that I calculated was possible for where
he was at I think is is a little bit a
little bit north of that
and I was like dude I was like I was
like first of all this is crazy
congratulations second of all
my world view is that like dude shopping
centers like is this still a thing like
aren't you
is this not dying like in my world in
the tech World we're just like
everything's going online everything's
e-commerce you know you're going You're
swimming against the current and I go am
I just wrong about that or what's going
on how do I I mean Hobby Lobby folks are
always gonna need a Lobby to hobby bro
like they're they're they're they're
they're going in real life like so
that's what he said he goes you're right
he goes but there are some specific
Trends some specific categories that are
going completely anti-training expanding
Like Home Depot probably because I go I
go how does it work he goes
like what's your Edge like what are you
doing differently than anybody else
because you're getting a dramatically
better result than anybody else I know
in real estate it goes well I'll get a
call from you know the owner of uh you
know whatever Dollar General or
something like that and they'll say hey
literally we're not the owner like like
an executive like someone an executive
there you mean could be the CEO it could
be the head of real estate whoever
somebody somebody at the top of these
companies and they'll say look we're
trying to get into Lexington Kentucky
um you know we want to be in that Geo
and we or we want more stores in that
Geo uh can you make this happen and I'm
like and he's like so they're not gonna
make it happen I go no no Slow Down slow
down I go so what why do they call you
he's like well they've done business
with me I'm like okay great but like why
aren't they just calling a broker like
or somebody in Lexington and he's like
he's like I need to start laughing he's
like uh he's like you know or even
specific more specifically I'm like so
then you have to find the right location
he goes no sometimes they'll just tell
me we want to be in this location
I was like then why don't they just
contact the guy from there and like just
do the deal and he's like I'm like they
have re these companies have real estate
teams he's like oh he's like yeah they
do he's like but he's like three things
he goes number one
most of the owners of these places are
like a pain in the ass for them to deal
with he goes they know I'm easy to do
business with why most owners don't want
to invest in their properties they won't
do any tenant improvements I will invest
money to build out the stores the way
they want
um and because I've been willing to do
that they want they would prefer to work
with me over any other developer or like
the average developer because I have
shown that I can build fast and I will
invest my own dollars into building it
okay second thing and I go but doesn't
that guy just think like man if I just
did this he goes yeah but it's
speculation he goes I know because I
have these relationships I know they'll
come through that owner would have to
like on spec invest in in maybe
improving something part of their
property in order to make it more
inhabitable I'll just do it and by the
way so he gets the Hobby Lobby like
interest then he can go get a loan and
tell the bank hey I got interest uh in
this therefore not even that you know
he'll get the interest then he'll go tie
up the property he'll commit to buy it
but he doesn't have to have the money
right away he has 90 days or whatever
he's got to like close the thing 30 days
60 days whatever it is and in that time
he then goes against Hobby Lobby to sign
the lease then he goes to the financiers
he says here's the here's a property
with a signed 10-year lease
from a you know from a highly reputable
client can I now get financing it sounds
like the best business ever
yeah exactly and they're like oh Hobby
Lobby is not going down to business
anytime soon you have a 10-year tenant
yeah this is an easy this is all easy
so then he was like he's like I was like
okay so okay I kind of buy that the mom
and pop owner of these like you know
they own like one or two shopping
centers three shopping centers they're
not like they're more scared than they
are more fearful than they are greedy
they're not investing in it okay I buy
that some people might fall into that
what else what are your other edges he
goes I don't die by paralysis by
analysis he goes these guys will
something on page seven of the lease
will get them all tied up hey goes
they'll just get like some Covenant
they're really worried about he goes I
have like basically like a standardized
deal with these guys my leases are like
clean and simple and like you know I'm
willing to Bear some risk these are not
like the most iron-clad bulletproof
every every inch of every part of my
body is covered and can't be exposed
he's like you know I just don't die by
paralysis by analysis like these guys
will just die in the deal making process
of the lease because they get worried
about stuff that really doesn't matter
I've been doing this for long enough
that I understand look if things go
wrong I have a plan B a plan C Plan D I
don't have to make plan a this
completely fully insured thing okay
that's interesting tell me more and he
goes
he goes the other thing is that um
they will have like um he gave me some
other deal making points but I'll leave
those out some of those are you know
maybe a little like I don't know
personal or secretive I guess but I go
okay what about these tenants I go who
are these people who's trying to expand
I thought the whole Retail Landscape is
like shrinking and collapsing uh and
Amazon's killing everybody he goes yes
but there are certain categories so he
goes anything DIY so Hobby Lobby is an
example of this DIY people like to go in
they like to see the stuff they like to
have the stuff they need a bunch of
inventory in a big space
um so they're willing to rent these big
stores he goes another one anything that
caters to the Black and Latino Community
it goes for some reason those groups are
not buying online as much as you know
white white or Indians or other other
races they're not buying online their
stores are still thriving and he goes
and I asked them you know like why do
you think uh it'll be like um Burlington
Coat Factory got it or uh things like
that he's like for building Factory he's
like a lot of these places they're not
just like oh I just need a shirt let me
go buy the shirt okay if you wanted to
do that Amazon might be more convenient
or ordering online might be more
comfortable like I need a coach
it's a hangout it's like this is the one
place we go when we leave the house we
go for an outing and we go to this place
and um he's like so that is like a big
piece of like it's like part of their
lifestyle is to go to stores and hang
out and you know do the whole do the
whole nine he's like so those stores are
all thriving
he goes the third one is anything that's
like super low end so Dollar Store
um Style Style things because they're
actually cheaper than online and they
don't have to have the shipping problems
and so people if if you want the lowest
price that's still the place to go
fourth is he goes like your wife and my
wife home goods and Home Improvement so
go to Home Goods it's like he goes
they're treasure hunter treasure hunt
experiences
[Music]
TJ Maxx Ross uh Marshalls uh Home Goods
uh things like that he goes they go
because there's a joy in finding an
amazing deal yeah and so they they don't
want the most efficient experience where
they just go online and they just buy
the thing and they're done there's this
actually like the joy of the hunt so
they want to go to this big messy store
and they want to find gems and they want
to do that and again that's their outing
that's their fun that's their Hobby and
so the retail store still really matters
and so he gave me this like list of
categories that were like still
expanding and I thought that was pretty
interesting it's like
some of the the Nuance that you don't
really pay attention to unless you're
like in that field and so I just
appreciated kind of talking to somebody
super fascinating knows their stuff in
that area how many people work at this
person's company
like less than a dozen
no it's probably like somewhere between
20 and 30 I would say overall man that
seems like
it seems too boring for me like I I
think I would I for some reason I pick
things that probably make less money but
are more dopamine generally boring but
they do high deal volume he said he had
done like 80 or 100 transactions this
last year which is just that's a doing a
real estate deal every three days
basically which is just an insane amount
of volume he's like there's a reason
that's not normal but like
the whole real estate world has shifted
so I needed to shift my portfolio
um accordingly like what are my what are
my generational holds what are my you
know quick quick opportunistic buys and
what are my B properties that I need to
offload because interest rates are
changing and the real estate Market's
about to you know crash so I need to do
this he goes I remember he goes I
remember in 08 I was the guy who was
like I'm gonna do real estate like
because real estate had been good for
like you know eight straight years he's
like so I was running into the burning
tunnel and people are just handing Me
properties I'm like wow this is
incredible he goes now I realize you
want to be the guy on the way out and
hey here you go Bud have fun have fun
with this property yeah it's all the
papers all the numbers look good because
the last five years have been fantastic
last seven years been fantastic but the
next seven years might not be the same
and he's like you know I know now he's
like now I've learned which which way to
go in the tunnel when it's burning what
skills or attributes does this person
have you think that sets them apart
extremely aggressive they are they're
Impressions when you talk to them you
almost feel like at any given moment
like uh
it's like are we are we are we laughing
or are we fighting what's happening here
like they're a very friendly person it's
not bad it's not nothing wrong with that
but they are aggressively minded where
it's like we play to win uh like the way
they raise their kids is to win it's
like um like they're kids like you know
if they do something bad they don't go
to timeout they do 20 burpees and it's
like you know you know that's like just
like standard it's like okay before
dinner we're gonna go run wind Sprints
and then like you know that's just how
we do things before dinner
um and like girls boys two-year-old 10
year old doesn't matter like whoever you
are this is how we are how we roll now
you're back you just got a lot of lawn
care Duty yeah I mean
exactly like there's a there's just a
play to win mentality that's the first
thing second thing is giant giant chip
on shoulder
massive insecurity daddy didn't love me
uh Daddy was mean to me
um people said I wasn't uh people
said I would never be something hold on
to that use that as fuel
um and that same thing that kind of like
and you know they'll say like yeah that
stuff doesn't bother me anymore it's
like yeah but you brought it up to me
eight times in the last three years so
like I think there's like you haven't
let it go that's for sure you know I
think you've used it to a very very
productive end for sure but that chip on
your shoulder is like you know what do
they say chip on shoulder equals chip
and Pockets uh chips and pockets that's
that's what's happening so
um that's the second trait third is
amazing at deal making negotiation deal
making Gift of Gab
um spends very little time in front of
computers spends a lot of time in front
of people or on the phone tons of time
on the phone and like I feel like for
Our Generation like how much time do you
that I hate talking on the phone
I just it's like talking to you know
potential business things on the phone
like I spend essentially zero and in
fact if even if there's a business
opportunity like hey I'd love to do a
call like I just tell them straight
about hey I hate doing calls but if you
write it down like I'm happy to respond
yeah just to like a voice memo yeah like
I'm not I'm not doing any of that that's
hilarious
um yeah so this person spends a lot of
time on the phone and they do that to
gather tons of info and they'll just if
I they're like driving a bunch they'll
just dial okay I'm driving four hours to
go see this property in that time I'm
gonna make 14 phone calls or whatever
and I'm hey brother what's going on what
you seeing oh what happened to that
property you had out there oh you having
trouble well send me the numbers let me
take a look maybe I can help you out
blah blah you know like and they're just
constantly surfacing opportunities or
information oh that guy's doing having
some trouble interesting like oh this
person you know they're underwater there
oh I know Hobby Lobby wants to be there
so I'm gonna you know okay good let me
let me make that happen and so they just
find these these I love learning that's
one of the traits dude I love it
um very different like honestly pretty
standard for the real estate world one
of the things I said so far are like
shocking to anybody that's in real
estate
but for us in the tech world it's a very
different play style it's totally
different set of strengths
you know activities than what we do so
for us it's like oh that's cool that's
new that's crazy to me dude by the way
my father is like that but he owns a
business where when he spends his
Winters in Florida he brings a phone
that plugs into the wall and he brings
the fax machine and it just constantly
called like hey which guy what you hear
and what's good and like the his company
you know sells millions and millions of
dollars worth of stuff and it's just
with a phone a fax machine and
mailing checks and just constantly
calling like hey what you got what you
hearing it's like that's just how the
business is it's crazy man and they kill
it
par here talk to me that's what they do
they go well they go what's good brother
what's going on or he'll call people
nephew what's up nephew what's good
Barbershop if you're gonna be cool
nephew you gotta be black and in a
barber shop I can't believe you're dead
it's kind of like that I'll be like
what's up nephew he just calls me with
nephew
he just calls people nephew
um all right well you wanna do one more
uh let me tell you about a space that
I've been
poking around and it's not something I'm
gonna do but there's definitely
opportunity you know I poked the The
Beehive and I heard some buzzing I don't
want to go near it but like somebody who
wants honey
that's a very good analogy together
what the next word was gonna be yeah you
just had words coming out of your mouth
not sure how the sentence is going to
end it it totally found its place
wonderful that's really satisfying right
so
um
so only fans Okay so we've talked about
only fans a bunch but let me tell you
the angle that I'm thinking about here
so
by the way I do not give a about
only fans everyone talks about only fans
the only thing I care about is brap
Barbie do you know who that is I think
that's her name bad is that it bad Bobby
what did you just say I thought it was
brap I thought it Brad the Barbie isn't
there like an r and an H in the first
word just an H wait it's bad that's how
you spell bad
yeah stupid I feel like you I feel like
you're up to speed on bad Bobby what's
her name bad Barbie what's that I don't
know bad baby I just know her as the
catch me outside girl from Mari but uh
or Dr Phil or some anyway
that's the only person I know and it's
like she changed like races was she
black now or white what is she she's now
black oh well
Google
bad baby all right
whatever she she she sweats she's Jewish
and her mom's Italian she really and
then and then
now she's being like criticized because
she's like the people say it's like
modern day blackface because she's like
really like changed her look uh like
when she was on Dr Phil she looked like
uh you know like a spoiled white girl or
something like that and uh anyways
whatever it doesn't matter what the
her name is she kills it she kills it
and like apparently she bought like a 20
million dollar help 20 million dollar
house uh so whatever so so bad point is
uh company crushes it so they do
billions of dollars in Revenue uh the
owner whose name is now public so we can
talk about Leo he's a fan of the Pod
front of the house he
um I think they he cleared or or you
know like the the company cleared 500
million in profits in 2020 or 2021 like
just an insanely profitable insanely big
business okay
and what is only fans only fans is
basically like a storefront where
anybody can sell pictures or videos so
you're selling content
and so you know I do I do e-commerce I
come from the Shopify world I know that
in Shopify Shopify is your storefront
that's your equivalent of only fans uh
but you use like this whole host of
Tools around it to make your store sell
better to increase sales
so you'll use clavio to you know grab
people's email addresses and then send
them automated emails I know where
you're going with this one you use uh
you know this app to uh boost your you
know to upsells automatically uh right
to cross-sell or upsell new products so
that you increase the dollar value per
customer so use all these different
things
only fans kinda has none of this stuff
but it has the same volume and the same
like you know like seriousness of any of
these other big storefront slash
Marketplace type of ideas and so I think
there's a whole world of only fans SAS
tools that can be built so like but do
they have an ecosystem
like uh you don't need you don't the the
they just use it on their own you don't
have to like plug into only fans you
just like
um it's not like a platform you have to
go be approved to sell under to be an
app like the way Shopify does you got to
be in the Shopify app but do they have
like so oh so they don't have but
there's no only fans App Store no you
just you just sign up and you just use
products so for example there are
products that are like chat bots so what
they do is somebody follows you or they
subscribe uh either they're a free
follower or maybe they're paying the
five dollars a month subscription but
where you really make your money is what
they call pay-per-view and so that's
where you sell like oh I did a photo
shoot uh whatever like you know I
dressed up like Catwoman paid 9 19 to
unlock right that piece of content and
so what these Bots these SAS tools are
doing is they basically are like hey we
will go message all of your followers as
if it's you being like hey did you see
my Catwoman thing I think you're gonna
love it 24 hours later
um like picture three in the album was
like just for you wink face whatever
right like this is just a bot and what
is this this is a sales rep that is
going around for you doing sales and
selling your content selling your
product and so the all the tools today
are pretty rudimentary they are pretty
um or they're just like they're just
missing certain things from certain
ecosystems and I think somebody could do
what uh what Andrew Andrew Wilkinson did
with Wii Commerce where he basically
rolled up a set of plugins and tools I
think that you could do that in the only
fans world now to do this why am I not
doing this
well
I don't want to deal with people on only
fans every day I don't want to be like
selling this content every day it's not
like
what's it called like it's not my icky
guy yeah that was put on this Earth to
do yeah but we got a bunch of friends
who are less you know uh a little little
less pretentious about yeah different
stands maybe we were not going to say
lower or higher standards we'll say more
wide
you know our bar is up here at someone
else's bar is not here it's just it's
different bars it's a little wider yeah
so if you're one of these wide standards
fellas out there I think there's a lot
of opportunities is a little wobbly uh
and there's a whole the whole ecosystem
right so if you want to start an agency
only fans agencies do really really well
right because they take care of the back
office they take her growth for for
these only fans creators
um I know two people personally that
have built only fans like just SEO
optimized websites that are like search
engine so it's like find a Creator
discover a Creator search for a person
no way and they're like metric sites
um and they've built them and they're
either like cash flowing really really
well like you know to the tune of like
you know 100 a month of free cash flow
or they sold them for like two three
million is one of them called fans
metric
uh I don't want to say because I kind of
already said some numbers so
um yeah there are like Ben we know too
personally that that did this and so
metrics like in any ecosystem same thing
with twitch it was like there was a
metric site and the metric site got big
then there were stream labs and
streamlabs made it easy for somebody to
like accept tips and donations and and
they made like a alert system so that
every time you got a tip or donation you
could automatically acknowledge that
person which which leads to more tips
and that streamlabs became an
indispensable tool for every twitch
Creator what is the stream Labs of only
fans dude that's so fascinating these
are the there is so much opportunity to
build SAS tooling for these traders to
build agencies to build you know a whole
bunch of different uh opportunities
around this ecosystem because most
people aren't going to go there
um myself included and if you do go
there the two it's like new and growing
so fast that the pie is big but it's not
totally saturated the same way that
Shopify feels quite saturated or you
know tools for i iPhone developers or
whatever seems pretty pretty saturated
do you follow um have you ever seen that
Tick Tock guy who goes up to people with
fancy cars and he goes hey what do you
do for a living
yeah of course uh what's his name
Brandon Mack I think or something Mac uh
it's awesome and yeah for some reason
all of it feels like all of the ones
lately have all been it's always hot
girls and they like make jokes and then
they they finally admit that they do
only fans
and only fans is one of those ideas when
when I heard about it like five years
ago I'm like who the gonna pay
for that like just Google it like you'll
see the same thing just like yeah Google
that person's name followed by the word
nude and you'll like find exactly what
you want like why would you pay 20 a
month for this and obviously they proved
me wrong and it's gotten to be such a
huge thing that it seems like if I go to
La do you see a hot girl in a fancy car
like just based off my me scrolling in
bed at night it's like oh they're
definitely and only it's an only fans
model and that is like totally new and
strange to me and that is what's made me
feel like oh this is like
going to be much actually much bigger
it's it's significantly more mainstream
than I ever thought like no one would
make like maybe now people will make
jokes about PornHub but like every guy
out there has like five or ten porn
sites that they go to and never in a
million years would they say out loud
what it is do you know what I mean and
yeah in fact I'm not even gonna say any
words for the rest of the segment and
now it's like only fans is like a thing
that like well we we talk about because
it's like so mainstream popular I find
it to be incredibly fascinating like
even just in the last four years we
started mentioning the word PornHub
because they would do funny skits like
uh during the Super Bowl or they would
like you know do fun it's like become a
joke but that has just happened by the
way one good idea was just to do another
only fans and so I forgot what it's
called fansley or fans only I think it's
fansly fansley is just like
uh if you don't want to be on only fans
come on fansley and they're just like
well we'll be number two it's fine we'll
make some different decisions like we
allow whatever like you know I don't
know what they're different like cartoon
creators or something like that like you
know I like everybody like a digital
dude like there's seven minute abs and
some fans leads just gonna be six minute
abs it's like yeah it's the same thing
we charge you only nine percent instead
of ten
exactly and so and then they're doing
pretty pretty well like they do they do
they do fairly well and when and so I
think there was just this was just one
of those winning ideas it was one of
those really big winning ideas I don't
know if I told you this by the way I had
a buddy who was a VC who
kind of quit his job and was going to
raise like his own fund
and then he was just like he identified
I think three years ago he goes
only fans and I go what and he goes only
fans it's going to be massive and I go I
think it's already pretty big at that
time it seemed pretty big for what it
was I was like dude how popular can this
get like that's what's it worth now you
think what could it sell for now I don't
even know
uh I don't know I think
very very conservatively
two billion is my guess and aggressively
closer to ten I don't know you know it's
hard to say like the all the market like
multiples just got changed so it's hard
to know also you know there's not that
many buyers for only fans so there's a
problem that's what I was getting at
yeah I can't really go public and
there's not that many buyers but it's
super super profitable and so my buddy
was like it's gonna be big I'm gonna
spend the next year trying to
get ownership and only fans I go what do
you mean like just I guess you're gonna
reach out he goes yeah but if it doesn't
work like I'm going to find a way to get
ownership I was like what he's like yeah
I'm just gonna like I'm gonna invest in
it I'm gonna help them I'm gonna do
anything I can
and he literally made that his mission
for like a year did he get it and he did
it he was able to like they didn't let
anybody invest but this guy was able to
go in and get advisory shares by helping
them out in all these different ways and
he did it he got a piece of it and he
was right he sent me he goes I remember
when twitch acquired us he goes only
fans will be bigger than twitch I got
bigger than twitch no way and I was like
dude I don't think you know Trish is
like one of the top six like most
visited websites in America or something
like that like most trafficked or
something and he goes
yeah you'll see and um and he was right
it passed Twitch in terms of uh users
and revenue in the last year and and I
was like wow this guy really like called
a shot of being super super bullish on
the only fans he was he was absolutely
correct dude does he also own 600
million dollars with the real estate
this guy sounds awesome
uh yeah I mean I'm a board I think I
think you know we Commerce is an
interesting company we Commerce is
Andrew Wilkinson you know fan of the Pod
or a friend of the potty comes in all
the time their market cap is decimated
right now it sucks right now but their
business is is pretty good like it's a
good business
um it's way undervalued
um but it I think it's an interesting
model and yeah I'm I'm bored with your
aggressive friend who pushed his way
into only fans do you do you have a
pre-game routine you do before this
podcast I listen to music and I review
all my notes that's about it like a
specific song or just like generally
whatever whatever is on well I use
Pandora and then I um one hour before so
I have my schedule locked in so for the
people listening we record for one hour
and so we're usually here at the top of
the hour then we start and then one hour
before that it's my quiet time where I
like review everything
a quiet time night well like people are
like messaging me and I'm like hey I
can't talk to you right now I'm
preparing and so it's my time to like
read notes and like I scan the news and
I just want to know what's going on in
the world yeah my daughter has that
that's great quiet time I love it
um what do you register invented this
great thing because she's like dude my
kids don't want to sleep and they just
want to play and so she's like I gotta
turn like she's like I don't even care
if they're asleep I just want them to go
to the room and just like not talk to me
and just stay in the bed and like have
fun so she created nighttime sister
playtime and so it's just like hilarious
thing where they're like oh it's
lifetime sister playtime and they get to
go run into their beds and like the Two
Sisters can play together but they have
to be quiet because it's nighttime
sister playtime nobody else is allowed
in which means don't bother Mommy and
Daddy and I just thought what a
hilarious Rebrand of go in the room shut
the door and shut up and so that now
whenever I'm doing something like even
work wise like with like co-workers like
our Ecom thing or whatever I'm like all
right snap time sister playtime like
that just means like don't talk don't
bother me with slack and don't talk to
me I'm gonna go do some work now that's
what I have I mean Daddy gotta go do
things dude I just like I blame
everything on the Pod and be like hey
cam preparing for the Pod don't talk to
me please because everyone knows it's
like a deadline why do you have a
routine
um I gotta well I kind of have one but I
was making fun of myself this morning
about it so
my schedule's similar I think to you
where now the morning is all locked in
where it's like I work out at a specific
time and then at the end of the workout
I do my like 10 minutes of like mindset
stuff that I do and and it's like it's
really good everything's really healthy
but it's almost comically healthy where
I was doing it today and I was like
I was like what am I I was like I'm that
cliche Tech guy that's like things have
changed uh fasted car yeah I do my
fasted cardio and then I I you know
seven and a half minutes in the sauna
then I you know 11 minutes unerrupted
staring at the sun it's like I have I
have sex for three minutes three times a
day it's a study show that it's better
like you know I'm like doing all these
like life optimization things that
really I'm like I'm not a huge fan of
those things because I feel like
individually I like all of them but
together I'm like am I this delicate
that I need to be like this uh you know
like am I like I'm not a I'm not one of
these like performance F1 cars or
whatever that's like you know has to be
like perfectly balanced everywhere I
don't want to be so fragile you you are
what you are what you uh didn't want to
be now I think that's good you look
better you look I think you look
significantly better than you did three
years ago that's for sure yeah but that
could be that could be anything who
knows who knows what that could be um
wait let me tell you really quick I
don't know if that's the morning routine
listen that's that's been more recent
speaking of morning routines I gotta I
was actually excited to tell you about
this so I'll tell you about it more when
I'm done with it but I met this guy on
Twitter named Isaac French do you know
Isaac French
he's that guy but it's a strong name
it's a strong name and that's why I got
interested in him frankly but he like
he's that guy who uh has that not gonna
lie French
dude Isaac French is his name I met him
on Twitter he's he's the guy who um he
bought a like a five acre plot of land
and like built cabins on it and turned
it into an Airbnb that's making like
millions of dollars in sales and but he
like he's only 25 and he like architect
and oh right we featured him on the pie
yeah yeah time ago and he like called
you and he told you all the numbers and
all that yeah and he like architect the
whole thing and he like he's also an
accountant so he did all the accounting
and then he even like hired all the
builders himself so he was the general
contractor just this interesting guy I
hung out with him I met him on Twitter
we actually I have eventually met up
with him he's really fascinating and
he's part of this uh religion I guess is
the right way to describe it called
Homestead Heritage and basically if if
you're an outsider it kind of looks like
a like a Mennonite night Society a
little bit you know like what Mennonites
are
no what is that you ever seen Amish
people
yeah so this is like he would not say
that they're the same and they aren't
but from an outside perspective it all
like looks a little similar and so by
the way those are the best descriptions
where it's like they'd be kind of
offended at this but this is what it is
well they're they're like objectively
not the same but like if you go I posted
their website in the in the thing uh in
the chat you'll see guys wearing like
those big wide hats and like there's
like a cow or like a horse like tilling
the land and they're walking alongside
of it and like a lot of the women wear
like the long dresses and like and so
listen to the description of their
religion it's a religion but it's also a
community but listen Homestead Homestead
Heritage is an agrarian and craft-based
intentional Christian Community it's
literature stresses Simplicity
sustainability self-sufficiency
cooperation service and quality
craftsmanship and so it's this like
super I don't understand any of that
what does that mean yeah yeah dude it's
hard to understand hard to understand if
you don't know but I spent time with
them as you taught me all this but like
basically
somehow they
they derived from like Chris from the
Bible or something about like it's there
like it's their Duty or something to
like create like high quality
craftsmanship-like stuff and to like
Farm on the land and be sustainable and
like there's you find God in like doing
hard work and good work and being honest
and creating stuff with your hands
that's like again this like huge
generalization from a massive outside
perspective but basically they like they
like make their own food so if you they
own a 500 acres in Waco Texas which is
about two hours of ish from Austin and
they like all their food is like made on
that land and like within the community
they share food with one another and
they're also pretty Savvy at business
like I don't know how that kind of comes
into this but like they like he's a he's
an accountant and so he's like oh I just
love like being diligent with numbers
and I'm like oh my God you're making me
weak at the needs my man like telling me
stuff so anyway this weekend he's having
like they're it's like their Festival
they do like a festival where you can go
in and buy like the their arts and
crafts and I'm driving 90 minutes to go
there and like we're gonna like sing
Christmas songs and like buy arts and
crafts and I'm incredibly excited to
show you uh like or to report back about
what it's like this community is so
fascinating to me and so it's kind of
interesting I'm imagining do you watch
the office you know when um Dwight has
his Airbnb I'm imagining that too yes
shirt Farms like that's what I'm
matching and you're gonna go meet Moe's
uh wow that is that is incredible you
know if you told me if you live this way
you can live till 200
I might do it then that that is how big
the cost is to me of like yo go make go
till your own food I don't know what
tilling is to be honest with you I don't
know if it's something you do with your
hands or your feet right like what what
is tilling I think it's when like a cow
like pulls along like a rake or
something and it like moves the soil
then you can like plant in it I
don't know but yeah dude it I'll watch
that I would bet my well I bet you these
people are pretty happy I think that
there is like happiness and simplicity
but like who the hell knows everyone's
unhappy but uh anyway that's what I'm
doing this weekend I'm gonna report back
well I like that it's kind of like Amish
people that love money that's kind of
already intriguing right like you know
tell me more yeah which is basically
exciting have you ever walked around in
Brooklyn and like I know Ben Levy who's
here like lived in this part of or ish
in this part of Brooklyn have you ever
been around like the Orthodox Jews
no but you said they like run the place
they run the place man and they like
you'll walk around in parts of Brooklyn
and they'll be speaking Yiddish or like
you go to certain stores and like
everything's in Yiddish and you're like
am I in a different country this is wild
and they kind of like like you like help
others in the community it's really
fascinating I love these I actually like
those cultures I think it's really
interesting that those exist
all right uh I think that's it for today
I'm Gonna Save the rest for next episode
[Music]